Chris Anderson: And now we go live to Caracas
to see one of Maestro Abreu's great proteges.
He is the new musical director of the Los Angeles Philharmonic Orchestra.
He's the greatest young conductor in the world.
Gustavo Dudamel!
(Applause)
(Music)
Gustavo Dudamel: Hi everybody in L.A.
Hi Quincy. Hi Maestro Zander. Hi Mark.
We are very happy to have the possibility to be with you
in the other side of the world.
We can speak only with music.
We are very happy
because we have the opportunity
to have this angel in the world --
not only in our country, Venezuela,
but in our world.
He has given us the possibility
to have dreams and to make true the dreams.
And here are the results
of this wonderful project
that is The System in Venezuela.
We hope to have, our Maestro,
to have orchestras in all the countries
in all Americas.
And we want to play a little piece for you
by one of the most important composers
of America.
A Mexican composer: Arturo Marquez.
"Danzon No. 2."
(Music)
(Applause)